[Música]
el pin ucrania el camino hacia la
seguridad está plagado de muertes para
tranquilizar a mi hijo mientras
caminábamos le dije que no mirara a los
cadáveres pero muchas familias aún no
han podido escapar de irving algunas se
enfrentan a una decisión extremadamente
dura permanecer juntas en una zona de
guerra o dejar atrás sus seres queridos
esta familia tiene que cocinar al aire
libre ya que no tiene electricidad en
temperaturas bajo cero el sonido de la
grasa ha convertido en un ruido de fondo
para ellos más allá de cinco años y daia
de 12 quieren mostrar algo
mira el agujero en el quinto piso era un
cohete
como ya no hay calefacción la familia
vive en una sola habitación
para las niñas duermen entre nosotros y
tratamos de estar lo más abrigados
posibles bien la familia aún no ha hecho
las maletas pero la guerra suena cada
vez más cerca
[Música]
y el camarógrafo ocurre para ponerse a
cubierto
la más joven se aferra a su madre para
consolarse
se mantener entre las paredes del
pasillo lejos de las ventanas
en el exterior los vecinos acuestan
detrás de un árbol hasta que pase el
peligro
el padre ya no puede más
preparen a los niños tú te vas yo me
quedo quiere que sus dos niñas y su hijo
mayor estén fuera de peligro pero su
madre se niega
prepárate y
nadie me va a obligar no me voy a ningún
lado los niños miran mientras los padres
discuten la abuela de la familia está
enferma y se niega a viajar escapar a un
lugar seguro significaría dejarla atrás
pues agarra a los niños y betis en un
hombre a medida que el peligro se acerca
la familia aplaza la decisión de huir un
día más